a lot of speculation about Daryl's
sexuality what's your take on that just
because of some comments the briefs are
made and that got people talking about
what are they talking about Daryl could
Daryl's you know yeah okay that was um
there was an I think an interviewer that
went to Robert Kirkman and said I know
you guys cross reference some of the
characters um and there's a character
named Jesus who's a real badass in the
comic book and he said is is Daryl
taking that over is he gonna be gay and
the guys Kirkman said I don't know we've
talked about it and we had it I had a
talk with Frank Darabont early early on
about would you do it and I'm like hell
yeah let's do it
yeah and that sort of cross referenced
to me but the thing is like when that
rumor went around you know I go to these
convention type things and they would
have you would have like like little
kids comer and they're like man I don't
care what's going on you're awesome and
then you'd have like guys my age or you
know a bit older to be like freaked out
about it yeah and then you'd have women
they're like you better not be not even
and and entertain the tooth day I I
would if that's the story that gave me I
would rock that story yeah yeah you're
not afraid
[Applause]
you